Here
we want to demonstrate three fundamental
concept. First we show that PCA and
linear autoenccoders are um equivalent
and then we add the deep learning
steroid to the linear autoenccoder and
make a nonlinear version and see the
improved performance.
So let's start with the common way that
we
compute the principal components here. I
assume that you remember this
but as you know PCA finds the direction
of maximum variance
and projected data over these directions
that are vectors of the coariance
matrix.
We use the top KG vectors and there are
ways to
choose K based on the amount of variance
that the chosen components will explain.
We discussed that PCA basically finds
this projection W that has a rank of K
and minimize this reconstruction error.
Okay, so here is our PCA class
basically
centers the data to zero
and then compute the singular value
decomposition.
If you don't remember SVD,
please go ahead and review this. And
then we extract the top K components
or the vectors.
So SVD basically rank all of these
vectors based on the top again values.
These already sorted. So it's enough to
just choose the top K. Here I'm
calculating the explained variance and
later we want to compare it to the
linear autoenccoder. And this is how we
find the Z or the latent space. It's
basically the projected X over these
components and now it is in K dimension.
We can decode it back using the
transpose of the matrix that we found in
the encoder. And as we discussed
basically these are orthogonal vectors
that correspond to a rotation and the
inverse of a rotation matrix is
basically the transpose of it. And
finally we compute the reconstruction
error which is the last that we
minimize. Okay. So with that let's write
the the linear autoenccoder.
Basically instead of using SVD we'll use
the gradient descent to find those
subspaces.
So I have class a linear autoenccoder
and remember here we find the first set
of weights that encodes the data to Z
and the decoder is basically just a
transpose of it. So we don't want to
learn it twice. It's basically tied
together. So let's call it a linear
autoenccoder with tied weights. Okay. So
we want to show that this linear out
encoder with a MSE loss and this tide
weights uh once converged it will span
the same subspace as PCA. This is
actually theoretically shown in this
paper if you're interested by Baldi and
Hornik back in 1989.
But here we are doing it empirically to
just show the results are the same. So
the goal is to show that the span or the
space of the Z is the same.
So note that uh when I'm saying span
means that that uh latent space can be
can rotate. It is still the same space.
Okay. So the weight can differ by
rotation but the span stays the same.
Okay. So let's define the init method.
So let's uh define a weight matrix that
basically works for both encoder and
decoder. Here we are starting with a
randomly initiated weight. Um ideally we
want this to be
small but let's just go start with this
and then this the input dimension
and the output dimension.
Well the output is the same just latent
dimension.
Okay, so
that's the initial parameters and
dimensions. Let's write the encode
method.
Okay, so that's what we have. Encode is
basically a linear projection of X by W.
And then we have the decode which is
basically the transpose or bring it back
to the same angle. Then we have the
forward which is the encode and
the decode that gives us the
reconstruction.
Um let's also return Z. So
in case we want to compare the the
projection
matrices
that eventually deface
spent by that encoder. Let's write this.
Okay. Okay. So we need to do this with
torch nugrad.
Maybe we can
add the decoder too. This way we can use
this function for to reconstruction.
Okay I think we should be good for now.
So now what I want to do is to
empirically show that PCA and this
linear AE or autoenccoder learns learn
the same subspace. So what we will do we
will first create a dummy data set on a
2D linear space that so maybe we can
frame it this way we can create a data
set that lives on a two two-dimensional
linear manifold but this two-dimensional
manifold lives in a 50dimensional space.
So both PCA and linear AE should find
this two two-dimensional manifold and
then we will compare the learn subspaces
between them. Okay. So let's generate
this synthetic data like I said on 2D
manifold but in a 50dimensional
space. Okay. So the true dimension will
be two
and the dimension that they live in or
the ambient dimension will be 50
and let's define number of samples let's
say th00and and then we will generate
the data. So basically what I want to do
is to generate X from a Z that we know
the Z lives in this two dimension and
then
reject this to the to this 50 dimension.
Then let's add some noise too. So that's
what we will do. So for that we need to
define this true W that we want to find.
Let's see the suggestion.
I mean we can go with this but I like to
have this at the beginning. Then we have
Z. So Z will so here. Yep. So Z lives in
this true dimension right which is two
here.
Okay. So then X will be this and ambient
dimension.
It should work. Let's reduce this to
make it easy for them to find. So that's
the data
and see. Okay. Now we can find the the
reconstruction error with PCA and then
compare we will compare it to the linear
autoenccoder performance. Okay, for PCA
it's enough to just call the class that
we wrote. Um we need to define the
components of course which here is the
oh yeah it's the true dimension now it
gets it okay so then we do the fit which
is basically the SVD and picking the
first two component then we can compute
the PCA error right let's run this okay
so and then let's do the linear
autoenccoderm so we have a linear
autoenccoder and
Okay, then we need an optimizer of
course to
handle this. Let's just use Adam.
What else? Oh, we need to center the
data. So, let's just use the mean and
remove this mean. Okay. And now we have
we don't need to really normalize the
variance. Let's just use this because we
want to compare the variances and we
didn't do it in PCA. So, so let's not
call it centered normal dance. We are
going to call it centered. Okay. So, now
we have to train. So, the training loop
will be first we need to initialize the
losses then for epoch or old training
loop.
Then we append the loss. We can do a
print and I want to plot the or print
out the final last two.
Okay. So let's run this.
Okay. Something is wrong here. Um
I think yeah the initialization that I
discussed here this is too large. We
have to reduce this. Okay. So let's try
again. Yes. Now what's next?
So we can also compare the the subspaces
if they are the same. To do that we need
to look at the projection matrices and
then look at the distance between these
two matrices. So a good distance here
will be forbinous norm and I'm going to
use that. So if you're not familiar with
it you have to check it out.
So to get the projection matrices we
have to use the basis vectors that we
found in PCA which was the components of
the PCA and for the linear autoenccoder
it was the weight matrix. So here for
PCA for example we have the projection
matrix this. So note that I didn't I'm
not going to compare the bases in the
latent in PCA and the linear rotic
encoder. The reason is they are not
unique and they can rotate. But here
when we look at the projection matrix we
don't have that problem and we can
directly compare them. Okay. So with
that this is the PC and for the AE
we already wrote the method. So just
going to call it and the distance or the
subspace difference
will be the
norm of the difference. How large is the
difference right and here note that yes
we are getting the item and we can print
this out. Okay let's compare this. Oh I
forgot the transpose and note the
difference is the is zero. So they're
accurately the same. Okay, great. So we
this is checked and we showed that um
linear autoenccoder naturally discovers
the PCA through this gradient descent
and the training which is pretty
important in the sense that the
optimization finds the right
representation in an automatic way or an
end toend way. We didn't really use any
math. we didn't use SVD or anything like
that. Okay. So with that let us do the
nonlinear autoenccoder and then we can
compare the representation of the
nonlinear autoenccoder with the linear
autoenccoder
and I want to show that this
representation is much richer and we can
find or represent much complicated
manifolds. So to do that I'm going to
use the data set uh Swiss roll data set
from scalar.
So if you haven't seen this is basically
a data set that looks like this. It's a
Swiss roll and it's difficult to find
this with linear planes because of the
shape. Also, we have points that are
that may be close to each other but they
are living very far from each other. For
example, in this point and this point
they may look close to each other but to
get from here to here you have to
traverse the whole manifold. Okay. So,
it's important for us to separate them.
So let's see how the auto includer can
handle that. Okay, so that's the data
set and I'm going to call the and I'm
going to build the nonlinear
encoder.
Okay,
so let's have the three layer hidden
dimension that has 128, 64 and 32
dimension and then with that we can
build the encoder. So first want to
specify the encoded layers can layers
and the previous dimension is input
dimension and now we can need the layers
together. So for hidden in hidden
dimensions we have we extend the coder
layers.
Okay. So then
we have this we extend
H linear with a rel we can add a let's
just be fancy let's add a batch norm
which requires heat and dimension of
course okay so we still need to add one
more right because we want to go to the
latent so
yes so for the decoder we just need to
mirror the architecture Okay,
just mirror the architecture that we
built.
Okay, let's see how we can do it. So
decoder layers
and priv
is latent we start from latent
and then for hidden
dimension. Now we have to reverse
right. So that's that extend
stuff from pre hidden relu patch norm
and then pre is hidden. Yes, good. And
what's the reconstruction?
So for the final reconstruction we have
we have to append of course the n linear
that will be our decoder. Now we still
have to
define the input and uh latent which is
this that we defined at the beginning.
Okay,
latent
good. So that's the construction. Now we
can easily call encode
takes in X and return Z self encoder.
The decode will be similarly
self but now it takes in C. We just need
to do a forward.
So reconstruction will be the decoded
latent.
And then we can return the
reconstruction just like before and Z.
That's our nonlinear autoenccoder. Now
let's do the experiment. So we will
generate a Swiss roll. We will sample
like 2,000 times from the Swiss roll. Uh
we have to inject some noise and the
resultant will be a three-dimensional
point cloud. Of course, we have to
normalize the data for a stable
training. In this case, because of the
complexity of the data, we are looking
at the spiral that is living in a three
dimension. We are expecting a
two-dimensional manifold to be found
which is just a plane that is just
spiraled. We will compare this
nonlinearity encoder with PCA and the
linear encoder that we wrote earlier.
Okay, so I'm going to code this up
because this is easy and I will show you
the final result.
So here is what I did. I have the
samples taken from the Swiss roll
normalization, some print statement. We
do the PCA and then the linear
autoenccoder. Of course, we have to
train that and then the nonlinear
autoenccoder. Here I reduce the
dimension to somehow be fair because
it's not really necessary to go that
deep too. Okay. So we can visualize the
Swiss roll both in 2D and 3D and the
most important experiment is the
reconstruction. We can also look at the
training curves. Okay. So with that here
is the result. Um so you see the
reconstruction error of course for PCA
and linear autoenccoder is the same
because they are the same but here is
the reconstruction error for the
nonlinear autoenccoder which is
extremely small compared to the other
two and here is the result looking at 2D
and then the 3D reconstruction you see
that the PCA reconstruction is basically
just giving us a much simplified
reconstruction that's why it's very poor
in the reconstruction error. As you see
here and for the nonlinear autoenccoder
you see the training is going down
smoothly. That's how we show that the
nonlinear autoenccoder
can handle much more complicated
data sets and then finds better
representation of that.